[Music]
gyeo storm genius storm is directed by
to someone who directed some episodes of
the librarians I guess I know look at
the trailer it looks like it's gonna be
a disaster movie which we've seen a lot
of disaster movies every disaster you
could possibly have we have had a movie
about it so now we've got to change up
the causality this causality is the per
bunch of satellites as a net around the
world that allow us to control the
weather about somehow looks like it's
malfunctioning and causing disasters on
earth or someone's using it for Gaius
so now Gerard Butler who designed the
thing has to go up there and stop it
which means this scene in the poster
with him and his daughter and a big
toddler that never happens her girl is
never near a tidal wave Gerard Butler
never holds her as the world looks like
it's gonna end he's not even on the
planet for the majority of the movie
really the thing is if this movie
committed to its absurdity a string of
satellites that controls whether that is
causing disasters that actually could be
fun but this movie doesn't do that it
tries to be convoluted it more or less
is Gerard Butler up there playing
detective which feels like a great beat
Tom Clancy's story in space and just
drag this movie down man because on
earth you're really not rooting for
anybody really there's someone down on
earth also investigating but no one's
really amidst the disasters no one's in
ground zero of any of the disaster in a
respectable disaster movie you need that
you have risk you have danger it works
in this movie it's like you're not doing
it fast enough you know what another
city got wiped out what says we need to
fix it and get it done time is running
out then a bunch of faceless extras
getting killed
really cinematically speaking doesn't do
it for him he needs something to latch
on to this one's like put the human race
is in danger well the human race [ __ ]
sucks try again that's why you need
individuals to root for in the danger
that don't suck and a movie with
disasters some of the CGI spill right
some of it's a lot less than all right
really this movie's a made-for-tv movie
that happened to premiere in theaters
like who's like Gerard Butler's in it we
can't have it premiere on TV because
that means his career is now done have
you seen London has fallen this can't
premiere on TV for Gerard this movie did
one thing for me and that was allow me
to go okay this science doesn't work
we're in the future I have to assume
this is far into the future at the
beginning it's like in 2019 things sucks
so we fixed it with this but that
doesn't mean
takes place in 2019 it can't a tech
involved in creating this say I have to
assume this is centuries down the road
optimistically decades but apparently we
still use fossil fuels to launch a bunch
of space shuttles so we haven't run out
of that shed dudes playing a video game
with the ps4 controller is easy just
playing retro games that's like the
equivalent of someone now playing Atari
on a space station you know this really
old [ __ ] video game because we have
all this tech that took so long to make
but you just throw that out because
you're like alright disaster movie so
impress me disaster movie let's have
popcorn fun cuz movie takes itself too
seriously to be popcorn fun the movie
tries to be a few different things you
can't do they can't be some weird
Frankenstein Frank and [ __ ] hybrid
disaster movies doesn't work guys in the
end I was thinking this is one of those
movies that could be saved with a couple
beers maybe a couple of rum and cokes
but it relies so much on exposition and
the investigative aspect of it you can't
just casually watch it you have to lock
in because you have to lock in the movie
just bores you nothing in this movie
really stands out except for the fact
that it would have been so easy to make
a disaster movie about satellites that
make disasters fun movies just isn't fun
so I'll say I'm not gonna remember Geo
storm in t-minus one day yeah I've
already forgot and I have a confession I
was actually at my brother's birthday
party and he was like I'm going to crack
open my SNES classic yes he has one and
I was like dude I would love to but I
have work to do I must do my job I have
to watch and review Geo storm I Love You
Man so I wasn't there for that I watched
this [ __ ] thing so I'm just letting
you guys know if YouTube is your hobby
your job whatever if it's what you do
don't skip out on brother time that
includes playing the SNES classic with
your brother to watch a shitty [ __ ]
movie even if you have to review cuz
you're gonna walk out you're gonna be
like I made the wrong call alright guys
so Geo storm have you seen it what did
you think about it or what's the worst
disaster movie out there
Independence Day resurgence probably but
who knows so whatever it is whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you
[Music]